more than two years since the conflict
began tigraine Rebels have started
handing over weapons to Ethiopia's
federal government
it's part of a peace agreement signed
two months ago
as per the agreement disarmament needs
to be carried out we have disengaged
from our front lines
tdf has also done the same thing we have
done this by agreement
the leaders of the tagorean rebels
dominated Ethiopia's politics and
Military for nearly 30 years after prime
minister ABI Ahmed took office in 2018
they defected with a substantial faction
of the army and its weapons
African Union inspectors were there to
see them being handed back to the
government we have seen the handing
and taking over
of military Hardwares
by above the grand Defense Forces
and Ethiopia National Defense Force
the peace deal also stated that foreign
forces should leave to gray eritrea's
army fought there on the Ethiopian
government's side
access to De gray is restricted but
humanitarian workers say Eritrean
soldiers are still there they've been
accused of executing and raping
civilians activists say the degree and
Rebels have been pushed into a corner
they have been told in no uncertain
terms by the Au and by the European
Union and by the Americans that they
have to accept whatever is offered to
them and what has been offered to them
now is the trickling of Aid in exchange
for the total disarmament of the
technical Defense Forces the only forces
that were protecting was to grab people
against the barbarity Unleashed by
Eritrean forces and the Ethiopian forces
the UN estimates half a million people
have died from violence and starvation
during the conflict
hundreds of thousands of others have
been forced from their homes people are
still waiting to see if they'll be
lasting peace or Justice Malcolm Webb Al
Jazeera